А що було б якщо б військові встали і
пішли як встали і пішли сьогодні народні
депутати це наша позиція тут це ми маємо
тримати цю
позицію ми її не тримаємо депутати
розійшлися вони чимось дуже зайняті чим
я не знаю я не знаю чим і це ганебно І
це неправильно і тому друзі давайте
терміново зміняти наші підходи давайте
Терміново ставити ритети правильно саме
головне- військові саме головне- Військо
це наше завдання а значить забирати
гроші з марафонів нікому не потрібних з
політиканства з бюро економічної безпеки
яке такі кошмарить бізнес Який ще дає
робочі місця затискати прокурорів і
інших так щоби вони не могли собі торти
за 100 000 грн на весілля купувати і
таке весілля робити що всім соромно в
країні